yeah fists yes wait I want to switch
there we go okay I feel hi everyone I'm
Kelsey and welcome to my cafe I've been
a barista for like a little bit over
three years now and I'm so excited to
have you on my new space so today I'm
serving up some cold brew a mocha with
raspberry syrup and caramel drizzle some
beautiful black coffee some matcha green
tea with soy and vanilla and some house
blend with cream
[Music]
I think I'll be like half and half maybe
to be honest I think I'll get a couple
right maybe Kelsey's cafe is open for
business that's like my dream come true
oh my goodness hi Nadia I'm Kelsey so
nice to meet you nice to meet you too do
you like coffee first
yeah I love I love coffee awesome do you
drink it like every day like what's like
your routine I guess if you do have
coffee yeah I try to have some coffee
once a day at least a little bit of an
addict when do you normally have it just
in the morning god yeah try to have it
before noon gotcha
do you like it just broke because you
like media or like because you like
really like it too um both both yeah
okay they saw what you said to me I
think you'd order a house done with
cream
I'm LuAnn nice to meet you Lily and I'm
Kelsey - you're very energetic based off
of your appearance I would say the mocha
with raspberry syrup and caramel drizzle
it's kind of a fancy your option and
you're dressed in a very fancy beautiful
dress thank you what's like your milk
preference just like whole milk or cream
what do you like your coffee with do you
like it just like alone or like with
food I mostly just get my coffee to go
just ahead to work or if I'm just going
somewhere it's not something a drink
it looks like mostly just like - to buy
something quick let me say black coffee
[Music]
thank you so tell me like um how
dependent are you on coffee I'd say I'm
pretty dependent on coffee God yeah do
you like like to go to cafes and hang
out or do you just like to make coffee
at home I do both I love going to a cafe
with friends or just alone doing some
work but I also would like to make my
own coffee at home do you like it hot or
cold I do both cold brew today all right
Thank You Kelsey it's nice to meet you
I'm Nate so tell me um do you like
coffee I love coffee love coffee
okay amazing do you like it kind of like
sweeter or I mostly drink it just
straight up straight up I received the
option to like the wit cuz now I'm like
after all the customers are coming I'm
like figuring it out now do you drink
like whole milk plant base no like
what's your type
I don't drink milk that often but I go
plant-based base yeah
all right so base up what I have left
I'm gonna give you some nice matcha
today thank you thanks me nice to meet
you what's your name
I'm Emily Emily nice to meet you I'm
Kelsey well thanks for coming thank you
for coming my pleasure
anything for coffee do you like to make
coffee or like you like to like go hang
out with friends or like just like pick
up coffee to go copy for me is like a
very personal ritual I feel like I've
ruined many a coffee shop with like
coffee meetings or like work things yeah
so like I save those for Starbucks but
like my spots are like my spots you know
what I mean
yeah so but then I'll also make the
coffee at home on the weekends sometimes
all right so I got a special tree for
you remaining I'm so excited it's kind
of like a dessert you know so like I
would like maybe like save it for later
if you want but like I got some fresh
smoked ax with raspberry just chop them
up in the back wow it looks delicious
how do you feel about your I feel like I
definitely got all of them wrong how
many do you think you got right gotta
find one right hmm I would say probably
the cool brew honestly I feel like my
initial impressions were probably better
but like if I could guess now and switch
them I feel like I could get more
correct if you had to switch anybody's
coffee you can go ahead and do that
right now
perfect can I like okay cool all right
[Music]
okay I'm gonna give this to you you just
wait switch there we go I made those
switches cuz I think like sometimes you
just have to go with your gut
based off of some of the answer is like
um like someone mentioned that they like
coffee with cream so I was like okay
that they make sense I'll mash it with
that I don't know like we're gonna be
like a fan oh my god oh no I did give
some celebratory coffees for like you
know beautiful dress or like no I don't
know I mean I hope I'm right but like I
hope no one's mad at me if I'm wrong
okay I feel alright better I feel like a
little better so changes how many right
now three good evening alright so I
think I got Nadia Tyler and Nate correct
[Music]
[Laughter]
what was your actual drink order
I get black coffee you get black coffee
hi mate so tell me what do you normally
order so sorry I messed up I'm the macho
latte your macho God yeah okay
shoulda known with this plan face it if
I'm going to get coffee somewhere I'll
go with matcha but if I'm getting it for
free or like at a gas station then I'll
usually just go black coffee but I like
I like to treat myself so sorry about
the mess up what would you access so
fine cold brew down oh yeah that's me
yeah this was probably still very
delicious thank you and I'll make you
some fresh cold brew it'll take me 16
hours but already worth away oh you had
me right the first time around I did
with the coffee with cream
oh no I was like I don't know success I
lie I trick Jerry I know is 1 out of 5
but like some said that they actually
did like the drinks that they cut that I
gave them even though they like didn't
order it you know I hope I put a smile
on their face regardless so so that
matters healthy's cafe is officially
closed
goodbye
[Music]
you
[Music]